angel is with us in Baltimore hi angel
how are you I'm doing well Dave thank
you for taking my calls
sure what's up I want to know that
financially safe for me and my husband
to the one of occasions where where's
and over taxes and I have some school
debt and I just want to get your opinion
mm-hmm okay well the the thing I have
figured out is that what you concentrate
on is what happens in your life and you
know can you go on vacation what you're
adults you have the money you can go on
vacation or you can put it on the credit
card and adults right I mean you get to
make these choices you don't need my
permission to go on vacation would I go
on vacation if I had a tax bill laying
there not in a million years okay and
how much student loan debt of you two
got he doesn't have any but I had some
about six thousand or seven times
I think what's your household income
thirty thirty thousand dollars and how
much do you owe in taxes I think it's
one thousand one hundred and sixty-seven
dollars okay doesn't one of you working
oh we're both working I'm looking for
the school system there's a a and he
works for a law firm it just got
certified as a paralegal son present
okay paralegals make more than thirty
thousand dollars a year in Baltimore
well he he just got certified so this
hasn't come in the mill yet it's gonna
come in June so he's looking for a job
as a paralegal right now we're gonna be
in the call center for size and curves
oh okay okay so your household incomes
getting ready to change okay so let me
restate this another way I'm gonna I'm
gonna be really nasty for a second okay
hold on you ready you got a grip you
gotta grab your you're broke
making newlyweds you just are starting
your career in your life you haven't
even paid your tax bill no you don't
need to go on vacation he's saying like
we can go in a group and pay each or
something make it cheaper what do you
think about that I think if you put a
lipstick on a pig it's still a pig I
think so too I'm yeah yeah
this is immaturity no you guys need to
get your freakin act together get your
big girl big boy jobs start making you
some money clean up these messes and a
year from now when you've got a little
money in the bank and you got no debt
then go on vacation pay cash for it
you'll enjoy it a lot more you're gonna
feel stupid on vacation right now
because if you go on vacation right now
you're going to be stupid is it would it
be safer like just a day trip like go to
an amusement park instead of making it
like a whole home sweet or something
kiddo you can do whatever you want to do
okay you're allowed to do whatever you
want to do you're grownups you're
allowed to do whatever you want to do
I'm telling you what to do but you can
do whatever you want to do